.
>> AMARA WALKER, THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S BRING IN CHIEF MEDICAL
ADVISER DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU'VE SPOKEN MULTIPLE TIMES
WITH YOUR COUNTERPARTS IN SOUTH
AFRICA WHERE OMICRON HAS BECOME
THE DOMINANT VARIANT IN JUST TWO
WEEKS.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU ABOUT
THE SPREAD AND THE SEVERITY OF
CASES THERE?
>> WELL, WITH THE LATTER, JAKE,
THEY DON'T KNOW AND WE'RE IN
VIRTUAL CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
THEM.
THEY HAVE PATIENTS THEY'RE
FOLLOWING AND THEY ASSURED US
THEY'D KNOW PROBABLY IN A MATTER
OF A WEEK, A WEEK AND A HALF AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE DEALING
WITH SOMETHING THAT FOR THE MOST
PART IS MORE SEVERE, EQUALLY AS
SEVERE OR LESS SEVERE.
IT COULD BE EITHER OF THEM.
RIGHT NOW IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE
THERE'S A BIG SIGNAL OF A HIGH
DEGREE OF SEVERITY, BUT IT'S TOO
EARLY TO TELL, JAKE.
WE REALLY NEED TO WAIT FOR THEM
TO GIVE US THE INFORMATION.
THEY HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
COOPERATIVE AND COLLABORATIVE
AND TRANSPARENT WITH US ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
VERY HELPFUL.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID TODAY HE
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE EXPANDING
U.S. TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS EVEN
THOUGH ALMOST 20 COUNTRIES NOW
HAVE CONFIRMED CASES OF THE NEW
OMICRON VARIANT.
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH THIS
VIRUS, DO YOU EXPECT MORE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS IF OMICRON IS
PROVEN TO BE MORE CONTAGIOUS AND
MORE DEADLY?
>> I DON'T THINK SO, JAKE.
I THINK WHAT WAS DONE ABOUT THE
RESTRICTIONS FROM SOUTH AFRICA
AND NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES WAS
MERELY BECAUSE WHEN THE
INFORMATION CAME OUT, ABOUT THE
MOLECULAR MAKEUP OF THIS VIRUS
WITH ALL OF THE MUTATIONS THAT
WERE OF CONCERN, WE FELT WE
NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING RIGHT
AWAY.
HOPEFULLY THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE
NOT GOING TO BE A VERY LONG
DURATION UNTIL WE GOT A HANDLES
TOO WHAT'S GOING ON, BUT WE DO
NOT ANTICIPATE FURTHER
RESTRICTIONS.
>> SOUTH AFRICA SAID THIS
EARLIER TODAY.
>> FIRST, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT
SOUTH AFRICA, SOUTHERN KAFRICA
HAS BEEN PUNISH FORWARD HAVING
GOOD SURVEILLANCE AND ENSURING
WE WANTED TO BE COMPLETELY
TRANSPARENT.
SO THIS KIND OF EARLY KNEE-JERK
REACTION TO BLOCK TRAVEL IS
PROBABLY JUST GOING TO SLOW IT
SLIGHTLY AT BEST BUT PROBABLY
HAVE LITTLE IF ANY IMPACT.
>> DO YOU DISAGREE WITH WHAT HE
JUST SAID?
HE SAID IT'S PROBABLY NOT GOING
TO HAVE MUCH OF AN IMPACT.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE BIG PICTURE OF
WHETHER IT GETS HERE OR NOT BUT
WHAT IMPACT IT WILL HAVE, IT
WILL BUY US MAYBE A COUPLE OF
WEEKS OF GETTING BETTER
PREPARED.
WHENEVER YOU DO SOMETHING LIKE
GIVE TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS, YOU
DON'T DO IT JUST FOR NO REASON.
YOU DO IT TO ALLOW YOU TO GET A
LEEWAY, A LITTLE BIT PERIOD OF
TIME OF MAKE A WEEK OR TWO TO
INTENSIFY YOUR PREPAREDNESS AND
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
BETTER.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY THE
PRESIDENT SAID AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY, NOW IS THE
TIME TO SAY, WHAT CAN WE DO
ABOUT THIS?
THE UNVACCINATED NEED TO GET
VACCINATED AND THOSE ELIGIBLE TO
GET BOOSTED SHOULD GET BOOSTED
BECAUSE WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE,
JAKE, THAT EVEN WITH VARIANTS
THAT ARE NOT SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED AT BY THE VACCINE, SUCH
AS THE DELTA VARIANT.
IF YOU GET THE LEVEL OF ANTIBODY
HIGH ENOUGH, THE PROTECTION
SPILLS OVER TO THOSE OTHER
VARIANTS.
SO WE HAVE EVERY REASON TO
BELIEVE, EVEN THOUGH THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY, UNUSUAL VARIANT
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER OF
MUTATIONS, THERE'S NO REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL NOT HAPPEN,
THAT IF YOU GET THE LEVEL OF
ANTIBODY HIGH WITH THE REGULAR
BOOSTER TO THE REGULAR VACCINE,
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AT
LEAST SOME EFFECT AND HOPEFULLY
A GOOD EFFECT ON ABILITY TO
PROTECT AGAINST THIS VARIANT.
>> YOU SAID THAT PCR TESTS,
CORONAVIRUS TESTS, SHOULD DETECT
CASES OF THIS NEW VARIANT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THOSE THAT USE
THE AT-HOME RAPID TESTS.
COULD OMICRON BE MORE WIDESPREAD
THAN THE ABILITY TO TRACK IT
BECAUSE THOSE TESTS DON'T WORK
ON OMICRON?
>> I ASKED THAT QUESTION JUST
YESTERDAY BECAUSE I WAS ON A
PROLONGED ZOOM CALL WITH OUR
AFRICAN -- SOUTH AFRICAN
COLLEAGUES.
AND THEY SAID AT LEAST SOME OF
THE RAPID ANTIGEN TESTS WOULD
PICK THIS UP.
HE COULDN'T GUARANTEE ALL OF
THEM WOULD BUT THE ONES THEY
WERE USING, HE DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY SAY WHAT THEY WERE,
IS THAT THE MUTATIONS DID NOT
INTERFERE WITH THE ABILITY TO
RECOGNIZE THE ANTIGEN BY THE
ANTIBODIES THAT WERE USED IN THE
RAPID TEST.
SO THAT IS A GOOD THING.
THE PCR TESTS THAT ARE USED CAN
PICK IT UP.
LUCKY FOR US THAT'S THE CASE.
>> DO YOU EXPECT THAT THE
OMICRON VARIANT WILL BECOME THE
DOMINANT VARIANT IN THE UNITED
STATES AT SOME POINT?
>> JAKE, WE JUST CAN'T PREDICT
THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT THE PATTERN IS
IN SOUTH AFRICA.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT SOUTH
AFRICA HAS BEEN SORT OF THE
EPICENTER OF AT LEAST THE
RECOGNITION OF IT, BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS THEY ARE AS GOOD AS IT
GETS WHEN IT COMES TO SCIENTISTS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PEOPLE SO
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GIVE US SOME
VERY IMPORTANT INFORMATION
HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK
OR TWO.
>> TODAY NEW YORK CITY MADE
MASKS HIGHLY RECOMMENDED.
WE'RE NOW IN THE THICK OF
HOLIDAY GATHERINGS, PEOPLE
SPENDING MORE TIME INDOORS
BECAUSE OF THE COLD WEATHER.
WOULD YOU URGE CITIES AND STATES
TO REINSTATE MASK MANDATES AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES, AND
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE PEOPLE
AND I'VE SEEN REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS SAY THEY DON'T THINK
MASKING DOES ANYTHING.
>> WELL, MASKING CERTAINLY DOES
SOMETHING.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY DOUBT
ABOUT THAT.
THE IDEA ABOUT MANDATES AGAIN,
DEPENDS ON WHERE YOU ARE AND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU'RE IN.
ONE THING FOR SURE THAT IF YOU
ARE AN INDOOR CONGREGATE SETTING
WHERE YOU DON'T KNOW THEIR
VACCINATION STATUS OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND YOU, YOU SHOULD WEAR A
MASK.
WE'RE GOING TO BE TRAVELING
SOON.
PEOPLE WILL BE TRAVELING FOR THE
UPCOMING HOLIDAYS.
YOU'LL BE IN AIRPORTS THAT ARE
GENERALLY CROWDED.
KEEP THAT MASK ON.
I KNOW WHEN PEOPLE GO EAT AT THE
FOOD COURTS, TO THE BEST OF YOUR
ABILITY, STAY AWAY FROM THAT AND
KEEP YOUR MASK ON.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A MASK ON WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE PLANE.
BUT MAKE SURE YOU HAVE IT ON
WHEN AT THE AIRPORT.
>> SO DO YOU THINK CITIES SHOULD
HAVE MASK MANDATES?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO SPECULATE ON
THAT.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS RIGHT
NOW.
RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR OWN
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A DELTA VARIANT THAT IS
OVERWHELMINGLY DOMINANT.
WE HAVE 60 PLUS MILLION PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED WHICH HAVE NOT YET
GOTTEN VACCINATED AND WE WANT TO
GET A LOT MORE PEOPLE ELIGIBLE
TO BE BOOSTE